- Good morning. I'm walking
to the train right now.
We're going to the airport today. Yay!
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] We're currently in the car
on the way to San Fransisco.
I am playing this really
basic app about Swift
before the conference so
I'm not wasting car time.
- We're stuck on the airport
for like seven hours,
so I thought I'd get some work done.
This is my new app. We
wanna launch it this week.
Excited to get some of it done.
- [Voiceover] Growing up I
actually did not have any idea
that I was gonna end up
being a developer or a designer.
- I never thought that
I could actually code
and make proper apps.
Because it was somebody else's thing.
- Wild Ski is a skiing app that we made.
It's a game where animals
come from the jungle
and go to the mountain.
- My first game that I posted
is called Operation B.R.A.I.N.
Growing up, I always hated math.
I think the way that it's presented to us,
it's like a prison. It's a cage.
Apps can change education,
and we need that.
- I have two apps that
are on the App Store.
One is a game called Knightly
Moves that's based on chess,
and then I have another app
called Healthy Food Compass,
which'll help you find
healthy food on-the-go.
- Right now I'm developing
my first solo app.
It's called President.
It's going to allow people to
look at, track, follow,
discover the presidential events
for the 2016 election.
- [Voiceover] I don't know who it is.
- We think ...
- It's Tim Cook, yeah.
- I would tell him that I'm
thankful for his existence.
- If I met Tim Cook, I would ask him
to take a selfie with me.
- I think I'd just hope
that I would have something
to say at all.
(crowd talking)
(camera noises)
- I'm so glad that I got to say that.
- Taking a selfie with someone
who changed my life is,
like I never thought
this was gonna happen.
I mean, I can't believe it right now.
(upbeat music)
- This is it.
- We feel very official.
- [Voiceover] What are we doing right now?
What are we waiting for?
- We are going to Keynote.
- Which we're super happy that we ...
- Got a spot.
- Got seats.
- Because I've been watching it from home
for the past couple of years,
and I really want to see it live.
- I'm eager to see how
it's actually gonna be
and feel the real experience.
(upbeat music)
- [Tim Cook] Our youngest
scholarship winner
is a 12 year old girl from New York.
(applause)
- [Voiceover] When Tim Cook mentioned me,
it felt really awesome
that I just stood out.
- I've always heard about it.
Like, "Oh my god, all these people want
"to go to the Keynote" and all that,
and then to even be able to go there
was just amazing.
- I never expected to be here
at any point in time when I started.
- I never expected it to
take me places like this.
- I'm just so excited to
use this new skill set
towards things that I believe.
- One thing I would say to
a girl who's just starting
is that don't give up just
because it's dominated by men
because in the future, it'll hopefully
be more women in coding.
- I would tell a girl also
to reach out to people.
To talk about her app,
get all their feedback
because from one email, we ended up here,
so not to be afraid to
share with the world
her app and what it does,
and then who knows where
that's gonna take her.
- I'm really looking forward
to continuing on this journey.
I have no plans on stopping.
(upbeat music)